at the start of the movie we are
introduced to a young man named bong
bong is extremely talented at cooking
and is the youngest Chef in blue house
which is the official residence of the
South Korean prime minister that evening
bong learns that the house is throwing a
dinner party for a Chinese Ambassador
the Ambassador is extremely sensitive to
Fishbone so bong is instructed to
prepare a delicious fish dish with no
bones bong heeds their instruction and
immediately starts preparing the dish at
nightfall the dinner is ready and served
to the Ambassador sadly as soon as the
envoy bites the fish he finds a hook in
it this puts bong in a serious dilemma
as several guards search The Mansion to
find him in the following scene a pair
of police officers investigating the
incident arrives at bong's apartment and
knocks on his door bong knows that he's
in trouble so he tries to escape through
the balcony while the officers try their
best to catch him in the process bong
unfortunately plunges into a pool below
smacking his head on the bottom of the
pool for some reason and he keeps
falling as a woman swims towards him and
plants a kiss on his lips when bong
wakes up he finds himself on a strange
bed in an even stranger room bong feels
something is wrong and immediately
rushes to a nearby mirror his reflection
surprises him as bong discovers that he
has become a woman he contemplates for a
second but finalizes that he must be
dreaming due to the fall bong creeps out
of the room to figure out what's going
on but finds dozens of women outside who
bow and refer to her as your highness
surprised by this bong runs outside the
building but suddenly feels cold in her
crotch this is when bong realizes that
she has lost her banana
bong is horrified by this and initially
believes that she's been trafficked into
a sex change operation however when she
observes her surroundings bong discovers
that she time traveled to the past the
realization causes her to go into shock
and she's eventually brought back to the
Palace the next day bong wakes up and
learns her current identity from a maid
it turns out that she time traveled to
the joseon Dynasty in the year 1851
moreover she now lives inside the body
of Kim so-young a royal Ward to make
matters worse bong discovers that Kim is
scheduled to marry King chol Zhang and
to become Queen in the next few days the
maid also explains that her body was
found floating on a lake after an
unknown accident occurred luckily the
guard found her and brought her back to
the Palace hearing this bong theorizes
that both him and Kim's Spirits must
have switched and infers that the ticket
back home is the lake bong asks the maid
to lead him to the lake as he plans to
jump in and return to the present sadly
her plan to jump takes an unexpected
turn as she lands on muddy ground
it turns out that the grand Queen
ordered the palace servants to drain the
lake overnight to prevent anyone from
falling into the water again bong is
disheartened by the news but still
reckons that water is the answer so she
desperately tries to submerge herself in
any water source she can find she even
goes as far as inserting her head in a
pail of water that is used to clean the
floors however all her efforts prove in
vain a few days later the wedding day
arrives bong is unaware of the Dynasty's
Customs but with the help of her
handmaids manages to complete the
required wedding rights that night bong
who is now Queen is invited to the
king's Chambers to sleep with him bong
is horrified by the thought and offers
the king some alcohol in hopes of him
passing out fortunately the king Falls
to sleep much to bong's relief the
following day bong wakes up with a
hangover and has offered some food
however she is disgusted by the Soggy
meal and passes a message to the Royal
Chef to cook ramen instead the chef is
confused by the term but tries to make
the foreign meal based on bong's
instruction the chef tries multiple
times to make the dish but bong is
dissatisfied with every attempt the
first dish is too healthy while the
subsequent dishes are too bland and
spicy eventually the chef becomes upset
and gives up
[Music]
asking bong to cook it herself bong who
still remembers her culinary techniques
decides to prepare the dish herself
which is pretty sweet because she could
have had that cook killed for that lip
bong enters the Royal Kitchen and
immediately picks up a knife her mate is
worried because the queen has never
attempted to cook since her childhood
hence the maid alongside the other
servants expect her to make a mess of
the kitchen however bong starts cutting
the vegetables with great speed and
precision much to the servant's surprise
she cuts everything perfectly and at the
right size ultimately cooking a perfect
dish bong takes the ramen back to her
Chambers and enjoys the meal with her
right hand made back at the kitchen the
chef is envious of bong's cooking
abilities and proposes that the food
simply looks good but doesn't taste nice
to test his theory the Royal Chef tries
the leftovers remaining in the pot
however as soon as he has a bite he is
amazed with how good it is so much so
that he even drops his damn spoon
foreign
ful encounter bong suddenly comes up
with an idea the new Queen realizes that
she can easily win over the royal family
with her culinary skills the lake was
drained by the grand Queen so if bong
can please her with some food she might
agree to refill the lake bong instantly
returns to the kitchen but the jealous
Royal Chef asserts his authority and
refuses to let her inspect the food
being served to the Grand Queen bong is
pissed at this and challenges him to a
speed cooking contest the Royal Chef
initially backs out from the fight but
accepts the challenge after bong teases
him a servant rings a bell and the
contest Begins the head chef takes his
knife and viciously cuts a bunch of
carrots however the Queen's hands are
faster and quickly cut some cucumbers
with ease after several minutes of
cooking bong's dish is ready and she is
the first to ring the bell thus winning
the contest the Royal Chef is upset and
argues that though speed is important
taste is the ultimate test of a chef
confident bonga Greece and requests the
Royal Cuisine inspector to taste both
dishes to see which is better the
inspector is fascinated by Banks Cuisine
and declares it is the better dish
prompting her to take charge of the
Royal Kitchen bong uses her newly
acquired status to her Advantage as she
analyzes the grand Queen's meals bong
discovers from her food choices that the
grand Queen is a picky eater due to her
recent development of toothache thus
bong decides to make a meal with a soft
texture for the Aristocrat bong gets to
work right away and begins making a
potato porridge first she pours some
milk into the pot and adds the right
ingredients as she occasionally tastes
the mixture then the potatoes are
eventually added to the pot after which
the dinner is served with some flour
toppings for a cohesive presentation
bong is pleased with the final product
and delivers it to the Grand Queen
herself the queen greatly enjoys the
meal but highlights that the dish is not
perfect as it arrived cold the
temperature change is caused by the
perfectly mashed potatoes to lump hence
slightly altering the taste also the
porridge spilled on the sides of the
plate also affected the presentation
bong is distraught to hear this and
sadly begins her trip back to the Palace
while in her carriage bong brainstorms
on the alternative means of delivering
food to the Grand Queen shortly after
she comes up with a stellar idea bang
sows a cloth and has her maid deliver
the fabric alongside some instructions
to the Royal Engineers with bog's
Direction the engineers construct a
special food delivery Carriage that is
properly insulated at all sides by the
cloth meanwhile bong prepares an array
of tasty meals and has the servants
deliver them using the newly designed
cabinet the grand Queen receives the
meal hot and enjoys it leaving no
leftovers eventually the engineers
returned to bong and deliver the good
news as the invention is proven to be a
success a few days later the king
organizes a huge banquet and invites
delegates from all over the country
unfortunately the cooks get sick on the
banquet day and the Royal Kitchen is
short staffed bong notices this and
decides to help out she disguises
herself as a man to sneak out from the
banquet and enters the kitchen bong
discovers that the pantry is low on
ingredients as the groceries which were
meant to be delivered that day didn't
make it with limited resources bong has
no choice but to get creative the queen
alongside her housemates prepares a
simple but unique dish of potatoes bong
Peels and wraps the potato around a
stick and deep fries it making it crisp
and crunchy the guests are initially
unhappy when they see the first Dish as
they expect something classier for a
Royal Banquet however as soon as they
try the unique meal their eyes shine in
approval as they Marvel at its taste and
thus fast food was born bong's second
dish is a bit more tasking as there's no
meat in the kitchen she creatively
decides to use beans to make a veggie
burger with a tomato relish at the sides
bong is pleased with her invention and
names it MacDonald
inspired by the modern McDonald's itself
the dish just like the potato serving is
a Smash Hit as the guests Savor the
mouthwatering cuisine for the final meal
Bond creates a classic jelly dessert but
with a Twist she writes special messages
on the jelly sticks and calls them
Fortune jelly as you get to read your
fortune after you're done with the
dessert the guests enjoy the classic
jelly and have fun reading their
respective fortunes despite the initial
hiccups the banquet turns out to be a
Smash Hit thanks to bong's cooking the
grand Queen who also attended the
banquet is impressed by bong skills and
finally asks her to make a request
without any hesitation bong asks her to
refill the lake the grand Queen grants
her request and commands the servants to
start working on the job sadly as it is
the 19th century there are no Advanced
machines to Aid this task hence the
servants can only transport water
manually with wooden buckets the process
is unbelievably slow as the servants
make a long trip from the town's well to
the lake bong is annoy by this and
swiftly comes up with a new method she
asks each servant to stay at one spot
and simply pass the bucket from one
person to the other the people are
pleased with the system as it makes the
job easier and faster they all continue
the task and work on it patiently while
bong oversees the lengthy process
several days pass but the lake is yet to
fill bong soon gets tired of waiting and
becomes desperate luckily a heavy
downfall begins which slowly but
gradually Waters the lake bong is
Overjoyed by the weather change and
dances ecstatically under the rain
[Music]
a few hours later the lake is filled and
Bong heads to the shores and signs her
name on a Cornerstone after which she
jumps into the lake and sinks underwater
just like she did at the start of the
movie when bong wakes up he is
astonished to find himself in a hospital
and sees an officer sleeping a few
meters away from his bed he quietly
tries to slip out but the officer wakes
up and a swift Chase ensues bong manages
to get away from him but two more
officers show up and Corner him
desperate bong jumps down from a high
platform escaping the men as he races
down the street he immediately heads to
a public library and searches for a
history book there he finds a
publication about the joseon Dynasty and
smiles knowing that he has now become a
part of History however his nostalgic
trip down memory lane is swiftly
interrupted when the chasing officers
arrive at the library bong tries to
escape once again but the officers
explained that they aren't there to
arrest him it turns out that the present
has been changed due to his time travel
to the joseon era now he is not being
chased by the police instead they are
there to protect him as bong is now a
whistleblower and exposed a high-ranking
official for corruption bong rushes to a
nearby computer and searches the web to
confirm their claims soon after he
discovers that they are telling the
truth as history and the present world
has indeed changed the movie ends with
bong standing on a street as he relays a
positive message on how a small change
in the past can greatly affect the
future also the life lesson that meals
are always better with bong subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching